[Music]
right there
how is the setup different to other
teams you've raced with
it's like night and day you know like
this team everything is
you know
done
for you to the extreme you know but like
my first tour when i was at baliwal
i brought my own like i was actually
s sis stuff yeah to the race so
um you know those go bars the big ones
yeah yeah
just bring yeah so
the the stuff they had was a bit rubbish
so you making your own bottles
it was
that's just night and day it's weird
who's the best advocate for performance
nutrition
um i think through me was always into
his nutrition one yeah like
these days like it's obviously a big
thing but back then it was kind of
getting more important it's always been
important but nobody's really thought
about it too much and he was always
looking at different things only
always like ten reached camps
oh he had so much like that stuff we
called baby porridge i've no idea what
it was but
um
and he's had like
those like fish
look like
fish spawn things yeah cool
i know what you mean huh
and he wasn't too bad or either
who's got the worst fashion sense uh
you're up there
i'm holding here
um
who's
i got i got an easy answer
oh yeah yeah yeah i did not think of him
yeah 100 failed yeah just a bit too too
out there yeah he's a bit heavy though
any
bit like
what's your favorite post race meal
we don't have it all the time but when
we do pizza and beer on the bus
because you have it straight away as
soon as you walk into the bus we had it
in norway i just did fresh pizza
proper italian
it's washed down over here
nice
is what you eat different if you've had
a win
i guess that's relevant to if it's at
the end of the race or mid race if you
win
a stage in the middle of a race nothing
changes because you've still got the day
ahead
which is still a huge focus but if we
get to the end of the race and you've
won or you win it one day normally
you'll
have something a bit more mm-hmm
end of the tour we only have burgers
don't we that's all yeah
i have to say it's twenty
six twenty one it's just
how do you relax and reset between races
it's a bit different now after having
max
as you know when once you've had kids
it's uh
totally different if you don't really
relax but you switch up you do
um just spend time with them and then
suddenly like you realize that what you
do is irrelevant really for that
um it's not because you get paid to do
that and that feeds them so it's
actually quite important
describe what the setup is like at the
team hotel
i think one misconception firstly about
team hotels is that it's all glitz and
glam
and it's not it's a lot of them there's
some great hotels and there's some um
not so nice and that's
the majority is not so nice majority are
not so nice because
it's provided by the race the
accommodation and if you think you can
have
throughout the teams on the staff three
four hundred people plus media common
sense everything you've got to fit
five six seven hundred people into
hotels in a village where you finish
where there's omni hotels so
you can get in some pretty
average hotels but the team do the best
to accommodate us and make sure they're
as
nice as possible you know bed in air con
there's not a lot you can do but uh
yeah
as long as it's clean that's the thing
for me ryder you least like to race
against them why
i mean you make enemies in races i think
this is part of the sport admit we're
fighting for position and we've got
rivals um
i don't have enemies yeah you do
yeah you do
uh
but to pinpoint
i'm gonna say more like go from a
different angle let's say a rider who
was hard to race against
i remember who was always like a bit of
a kneeling on our side was comfortable
because
as a gc rider he was so predictable
you would race
you know many other guys and you'd know
what they want to do they'd wait till
the end they wake the final climb but
contador was
especially he was behind of it he was
fourth or fifth if he was fourth or
fifth he was
six eight minutes he'd go on the first
climb he was a pain in the ass in a good
way in an aggressive way in
style that he had big balls so
i'd say he was the
trickiest to race against in the ground
karen what's your advice for anyone
looking to get into racing
uh well
i think just
get a bike first
yeah
it's a good start just get down local
try and find a local club and just get
some advice off
local riders you know
do it and
majority of people
are welcome in and even if you are new
to it you know it can be a bit of a
stigma sometimes like oh i don't know
anything about this i might look at an
idiot or whatever but
you won't but i've also started a
foundation you know this year
just trying to make cycling more
accessible basically so there's nothing
to do with racing so much but more
you know the only reason i got into it
was because maine he was down the road
outdoor belgium like your dad and mum
rode but my parents didn't so i never
would have done it wasn't for that so
it's just trying to
make it easier for kids to because a lot
of kids get a bike for christmas or yeah
birthday or whatever so
getting them somewhere to do it safely
or you know helping local clubs with a
bit more
money to get them into it it's a very
broad thing at the minute but um
yeah it's that's what we do nice list
yeah congrats thanks man
who's the biggest character in the team
i think we got a few
probably this is the most fun team
throughout the whole course of my time
professional sorry man i just finished a
race with flappy i'd say he's up there
he generates with happy yeah yeah i did
ramen he's up there he's funny i like
him um
i think me and you are quite big
characters on the team uh
going
through history
teo he's loud yeah i sat next to him on
the bus in norway it was
i had my headphones on um
[Music]
well
fools back in the day he was a big
character
he was good for like morale one he was
always just he's always happy when he
yeah you know you get dad jokes he was
just like next level stupid joke like
not even funny jokes but like
he's so dutch yeah he was good to have
around
what's your favorite ss product
and what's
your favorite flavor
so at the minute it's those chews beta
fuel chews
it's quite hard to say in it but you
know they choose the jelly things to
shop chews chews chews
um
but yeah no they are good they're like
you know
high in carbs easy to have
flavor tasty
wow there's orange or lemon yeah
i'd probably go
orange because i've had a lot of lemon
recently mix it up you know keep the
body guessing
yours
flavor flavor i am too is orange
but uh probably my favorite product as
well
because it's quite new aren't they and
we use so much of
the same stuff
that
your body gets used to it so they're
quite new they're fresh on the market
who's the best teammate in training
yeah there's lots of different factors
that make a good training part aren't
good chat
the right speed
pace for coffees
yeah that's minus one for you
um
i'd say me and you do some good rides we
get it done um i paid for the coffees
creator's good plans the route you don't
have to think about anything
um
many things to chat yeah i'll say you ah
i'll see you
i'm gonna chat
what's the most important thing you've
learned from each other
mr misses this one
thing i've learned from you well i
taught you
uh
what not to do basically i guess yeah
yeah you taught me how to be
professional about being unprofessional
uh do as i said i was like dude exactly
yeah
all right mate
i guess you should give out time do we
need to go through everything
well i can't think of anything
um
no i guess
credit requirements due when the time's
right i think you have a good balance
between
right now i have to work hard now i'm
professional you dedicate everything to
it
and then got the ability
to switch off from that which a lot of
guys haven't
and enjoy your life and i think that's
something that
i do as well and so i think that's 2018
was good enjoying that it was yeah yeah
but
you've got to celebrate things that
don't mean i think people get a bit lost
in the moment where
you know about the next race in it if
you do good stuff you've got to go big
enjoy the good times
what'd you eat before a typical race
if it's a big race i'll just
keep it really simple um
pasta
i won't go for any cereal or any
bread i'll just normally just go big
plate pasta
any sauce or just oil
uh
yeah quite just like oil and salt
because we're done sauce in the morning
yeah and quite quite simple oil salt
yeah maybe mash your egg in a bit
italians won't appreciate that but
what does it mean to be an ineos
grenadier
a robust
big
weapon of a rider trying to be like a
vehicle and obviously it's uh
i guess it's kind of like a status
symbol it's uh i'm certainly proud to be
half out of my jersey and what it stands
for um
yeah
good answer thanks mate
finally any superstitions
i don't really have superstitions but
i'd like to just oh maybe it is a
superstition but just do these the same
process before every stage so i always
put my numbers on on the way to the
start
you know i won't do it like the night
before or anything like that or i don't
know it's just the same
yeah do the same thing every day you end
up wearing the same shorts and jersey
and especially if you've had a good
stage oh keep wearing these even though
the next day you might bomb out you
still always keep doing it
so it's not really one thing that stands
out but it's more just that routine you
find comforting as well
there we are people
that's harassed
[Music]